let's review a little bit about what we
know so far about subtraction so if i
say five
minus three what does that mean well
there's a couple of ways to think about
it i could have five
let's say i had
five berries so one
two
three
four
five so i could have five berries and
when i say minus three or subtracting
three from it i can view that as saying
i'm going to take away three of these
berries so if i take away that berry
that berry and that berry so i took away
one two three berries how many berries
do i have left well the only berries i
have left are right here one two so i
have two
berries left just like that now the
other way the other way that i could
visualize or think about 5 minus 3 i'll
do it over here
5 minus 3 is to think about what the
difference between five and three is so
let me do this so let's say i have five
berries one two three four five and
let's say that you have three berries
yours is a slightly different color
you have three berries so another way to
think about five minus three is how many
more berries do i have than you have and
if you look right here well you see this
berry is another you have also one berry
there we both have one berry there we
both have one berry there but i've got
one two berries that you don't have so
once again i have two more berries than
you have now we can also think of this
in from the number line point of view
the number line point of view so let me
draw a number line
just like that
it's my number line we've learned on the
addition videos we can keep going off
forever and actually we could even go to
the left of zero and go into negative
numbers which we'll see in future videos
but i'll start at zero
zero
one
two
three
four
five
i'll just go i'll go up to seven
so if we do five minus three
if we view three is being taken away
from five five minus three means start
at five
if i did five plus three i would go i
would jump three spots to the right
because that's increasing the number of
things i have but since i'm subtracting
three i wanna decrease by three so i
decrease by 1
2
3 and i get 2
i get to 2 just like that
now if we visualize it from this point
of view let me draw another line number
line i want to show you i mean this is
i'm taking away 3 and here i'm saying
how many more is 5 then 3 even though
they're the exact same answer but there
are two different ways to think about it
let me draw a number line here again let
me draw the same number line i'll draw
the same number line
i have 0 1 2
3
4
5
6
7. so if i were to plot where 5 is on
this number line
so this is the 5 right there i'll put a
little pink square around it 5 is right
there
now 3 let me do 3 in this yellow color
3 is right here on the number line
so in this this way of thinking about 5
minus 3 you're saying how far what is
the difference let me write that down
here we're saying
what is the difference
the difference
between 5 and 3
between
five
and three and to figure out the
difference you actually have to say how
much do you have to add to three to get
to five so the difference here how
different is five than 3 well you have
to go up 1 and then up 2 to get to 5. so
the difference between 5 which is all
the way over here
and 3
which is just that far
is
the difference between five and three
is two
just like that
that right there is two let me draw that
in another box so that's two right here
and i wanna make these these this
difference between subtraction and
difference i wanna make it at least
reasonably clear to you because this is
this these are two different ways of
viewing subtraction but it ends up being
the exact same operation you're going to
get the same answer regardless of which
way you think about it
now i could view let me do different
numbers now let me do
seven
minus four
so i could view this as maybe i have a
seven foot long piece of wood
maybe i have a seven foot long piece of
wood it's seven feet long let me put if
i put a ruler up against it i would have
that's zero
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven so i have a seven foot long piece
of wood and then i could saw off four of
those feet
so if i were to saw four of these feet
so i saw off one
two
three
four how much wood do i have left so all
of this stuff right here i'm eliminating
i'm sawing it off
i'm sawing it off of the wood maybe i
should do that in a darker color to show
that i'm
that to show that i'm sawing it off so
all of this stuff is going to disappear
i'm grinding it away i'm sawing that off
so i'm just left with after i saw
the four inches or feet of whatever of
the wood i'm left with one
one two three
inches of wood so this is three so seven
minus four
is equal to
is equal to three this is viewing
subtraction as literally taking away i
sawed off the wood so i took away wood
now i could think of it in a slightly
different but
a slightly different way of thinking
about it but give you the exact same
answer
we could say 7 minus 4. so once again i
could have
the seven inch long piece of wood
right like that so if i put a ruler here
that's one
one two
three
four
five
six seven so once again a seven inch
long piece of wood and now instead of
taking four away of it i'm comparing it
so this that's a seven i'm comparing it
to a four inch long piece of wood so i
have another
four inch long piece of wood right there
that's my four inch long piece of wood
that's seven this is four you could view
seven minus four is taking four inches
away from the long piece of wood or you
could view seven minus four as the
difference between the four inch piece
of wood and the seven inch piece of wood
so in this case what's the difference to
go from the four inch piece of wood to
the seven inch piece of wood i would
have to grow
by three inches or i would have to add
or i would have to add
a three inch
piece of wood somehow the wood would
some have to grow by three inches in
order to become seven inches so these
are two completely equivalent ways to
view subtraction that's all a little bit
of review from the last video now what i
also want to do in this video
is start tackling slightly larger
problems but you'll see that it really
the number line applies just equally as
well as to kind of the simpler problems
that we've done before so let's do
let's do 17
minus
9. so just like everything else there's
two ways we could have done it you know
the the
more slow way is you could draw 17
objects let's say i have 17 chips 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17
and then i'm going to take away 9 of
them so i'm going to take away 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 eight nine how many am i left with
i'm left with one two three four five
six seven eight so 17 minus nine
is equal to eight but that took a long
time and you can imagine if this number
was a lot bigger would have taken me
forever to draw all these circles and
then scratch out things and it would
have wasted paper and and time and well
we have other things to do
so another way you could do it and
maybe this would be easier for you to
visualize is to draw the number line you
always don't have to start at 0.
so if we draw the number line if we say
let's say this 18
7 you could imagine i could keep going
to the left all the way to zero but i
start at 17
i could start at 17 and take away 9 from
it so i go 1
9 and once again we are left at 8. now
this was at least in my head a little
bit cleaner and faster than this one but
in either case you don't want to do this
every time you have to subtract 9 from
17 or want to find the difference
between 17 and 9 and then to realize
that's eight so this is something that
eventually you'll want to internalize
you you'll want to know by heart that oh
17 minus 9 i know that is 8. and by the
way 17 minus 8.
what's 17 minus 8
well
that is 9. and now why does all of this
make sense because 8
8 plus 9 is equal to
17. so 17 minus 9 is 8 17 minus 9 is 8
or 17 minus 8 is 9. when i say 17 minus
8 i'm essentially saying that is equal
to some number that if i were to add to
8 will equal 17. well that's 9. when i
say 17 minus 9 that's saying there's
some number that if i were to add it to
9 i'll get 17. well that's 8. so all of
these all of these statements are kind
of saying the same thing that 8 plus 9
or 17 or the difference between 17 and 9
is 8 or the difference between 17 and 8
is 9. hopefully
hopefully i'm not confusing so for most
of these for most of these
subtraction problems where the answer is
a one digit answer you you should you
should eventually have the memorize but
in your head it's good to be
imagining this number line let's do a
couple more of these
and then once we get once we have these
memorized or at least be able to do a
number line if we don't if we forget
i'll show you how to do any subtraction
problem for arbitrarily for super large
numbers
so let's say that let's say we're going
to do
13
minus 5. so once again i'm not going to
do the whole circles or the berries this
time i'm just going to draw the number
line
just draw the number line like that and
let's start it notice that says 14
5 and you just can't keep going
lower and lower you can go to zero or
you can even go past zero we'll talk
about that in the future but we start at
13
we're starting at 13
13 and we're going to take 5 away from
it so this is the subtraction view of
subtraction we're taking away
one two
three
four
five and we land at eight so thirteen
minus five we do this in a new color
thirteen minus 5 is equal to 8. now
another way we could have thought about
that i plotted where 13 is i can plot
where 5 is i could say look this is 5. 5
is right here on my number line what do
i have to add to 5 to get to 13. so
let's see how to go 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8. i have to add 8 to 5 to get to 13. 5
plus 8 is equal to 13. so that tells me
that 13 minus 5 is equal to 8. this also
tells me that 13
minus 8
is equal to 5. these are all
all of these are in on some level
telling me the exact same thing that the
difference between thirteen and five is
eight the difference between thirteen
and eight is five five plus eight
is thirteen so hopefully you have the
hang of that and if you haven't done so
already it it'll be good to practice all
of these
you know take taking a a teen number and
then subtracting
any of the one digit numbers from those
t numbers that's in general very very
good practice for you